EMILY FORTUNA: Good afternoon.
I'm Emily.
This is Siggy.
We are two engineers on the
Dart team at Google.
And today, we'd like to talk
about some of the features in
Dart that help make your web
app development experience
more pleasant and productive.
So this is not--
oh, OK, thank you.
This is my impression of
web development today.
It's thriving, doing well, but
things are maybe evolving
rather than being designed.
And as a result, a lot of APIs
are the way they are for
historical reasons, rather than
making the most sense for
the developer or being
the most readable.
Additionally, the way the web
handles errors is they handle
them silently.
And this can be great for
prototyping when you're trying
to get your app up and running
to begin with.
But when you have larger
applications, it becomes
frustrating when you're
trying to pinpoint the
source of your error.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Now the web also
has a great foundation
layer at the bottom that
you can use to
build a richer thing.
But when you're building large
applications, you start
needing to structure
applications, thinking about
models, views, controllers.
And to cope with this need,
people have created
frameworks.
There are actually many
frameworks out there, and they
[? noticeably don't ?] work well
together when you want to
actually use a feature or a
widget from one framework into
an app that uses another
framework.
So what we're doing with Dart
is we're taking a new--
click.
So what we're doing with Dart
is taking a new look at this
problem and giving you
a pleasant feel.
So what we want users to have
now, an experience that you
actually can feel productive
with it.
So we've taken all these APIs
that have grown organically,
and we revisit them and do a
design of the HTML libraries
so that now it all looks uniform
and something that you
can discover easily.
We're also taking advantage of
a lot of the features that we
have in the Dart language.
Some of the things helping
making things discoverable.
But it also helps that in Dart,
you can have a lot of
things that give you warnings
ahead of time.
We have the notion of optional
types and things that can let
you know if you're doing
something wrong.
But if you still want to get
going and ignore the warnings,
you can do it and continue
your productivity in the
typical [? prototype ?] mode.
EMILY FORTUNA: And as Siggy
mentioned, there are a lot of
frameworks that are being
developed to help you organize
your models and your views.
But they don't necessarily
work together.
And currently, they're
developing some web standards
to help you do this
on your own.
And Dart is keeping pace with
these standards and
integrating them into their
libraries in the language so
that you can use all these
features on any browser that
you want, today.
So we'll take a quick look at
how some of the design of the
Dart language and Dart libraries
have influenced the
HTML library in making your
web apps experience.
So let's take a little
example.
Let's say you have a collection
of nodes, HTML
nodes, and you want to
loop through them.
What might seem like the common
way, or what you would
think to be the default way to
do this, would possibly trip
you up in JavaScript.
So if you do a simple little
For Each loop, you're not
going to get each node.
Because you have this array-like
object you're
looping through, you
get your indexes.
And then you also get the links
and some other things.
In Dart, we return native
Dart lists.
So yes, you can have a pony.
So everything behaves just like
a Dart list natively in
the language.
And so you can loop
through your nodes
as you would expect.
And so native lists are not the
only thing we're returning
from the HTML library.
We've also adopted a lot of
other Dart types, for example,
futures and streams, and are
returning them as well.
So as an example, the
idea behind a future
is just like a callback.
But the difference
is that you--
so you have your--
this is your function call.
And when you had a callback,
you'd be
putting it right here.
With a future, you return the
future that when the value
completes, you do
your callback.
And the great thing about
futures is they
are easier to compose.
And so if you have a sequence
of events that needs to run,
then you can easily
have them chain.
So we have then, and
do something else.
As opposed to callbacks, where
you might have sort of
spaghetti callbacks going from
here to here and so on.
SIGMUND CHEREM: So you probably,
if you went to the
earlier talk today on Dart and
what's new in Dart, you
probably saw some more
examples on futures.
Just briefly, another thing that
Emily was saying about
composition.
Like you can see here, I
have this CatchError.
This is a way of now handling
both normal control flow and
exceptional control
flow with futures.
Another way in which composition
is actually
helpful with futures is that
you can run multiple
asynchronous operations
together.
They can run in parallel, and
they can then create another
future that waits for an
individual future to complete.
So when we're looking at the
HTML library, we know that
there's a lot of things that
are asynchronous by nature.
And what we want to do is to
take advantage of these types
and use them in this library.
Now one clear example
of that is the use
of a network request.
When you want to do a network
request, you create an object
in JavaScript, for example.
You set it up by sending a
callback so that you know when
the answer is actually
available, and so on.
In Dart, we can actually now
just get a future back.
And now you have all the
existing libraries available
to you that are functioning
on normal futures.
You can also use them on
this particular future.
And in the same way that we have
futures, there's a notion
of streams, which is
like a repeated
version of the future.
And we use that a lot in
events, when listening
[? for ?] events from the UI.
EMILY FORTUNA: So Dart
also has libraries.
And we use this to advantage
in splitting up
your huge HTML namespace.
So we have sublibraries.
For example, all the things that
are related to WebGL are
in their own space.
And also, in addition to
semantically grouping these
things together, this saves
you some typing.
So for example, we have all the
SVG elements and all the
SVG types in its own library.
So you don't have to type "SVG
element." You could just say,
rect element.
And so on with HTML elements
and others.
Dart also has named arguments.
And we use this to our advantage
in helping make the
APIs more pleasant
to work with.
So here's an example we have.
We're programmatically
initializing a mouse event in
JavaScript, or one
way to do it.
And it has a whole bunch of
optional arguments, but
they're positional.
And so if we wanted to specify
one non-default value, this
metaKey value, then we have to
put all of the other default
values in between.
And when you look back at this
later, it's a little hard to
read and understand what was the
programmer intending when
they wrote this line.
So with named arguments, all you
have to do is put the ones
that are not your
default values.
And so it's much more
clear what the
programmer's intent was.
Named arguments also are helpful
for discoverability.
One other way that the DOM APIs
deal with named arguments
is they take the dictionary, and
you can have collections--
or you put in keys
to specify the
behavior for these functions.
This works, but it's not
so discoverable.
So you have to look up what
magic keys do I need to insert
in my dictionary to
make this call.
In Dart, we've expanded a lot
of these dictionaries into
named arguments so that when
you're typing, the Dart Editor
will autocomplete and show you
that I had these optional
arguments that I could
also include.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Now, named
arguments are one way in which
we can improve discoverability.
And there are many other things
in the Dart language
that also help.
And the fact that we actually
have types, and we can
actually exploit this
in many ways.
For example, when we're talking
about CSS and doing
CSS manipulations, the very
common way to do that today in
JavaScript is to do strings and
concatenate strings and
put them together.
Now here, we can actually have
a specific type for talking
about the style, for talking
about the property of the
background color of this
particular style
object, and so on.
Now what we're going to do
next is Emily's going to
actually show you a little
demo in our editor and
demonstrate a little bit of
how these things work.
EMILY FORTUNA: So as a matter
of fact, this whole
presentation we're presenting
is a web page.
It's a web app.
And it is written in Dart.
And so our demo will be adding
on some functionality to your
presentation.
So in the presentation mode,
let's say I have this div
here, and I want to draw
your attention to it.
So might want a yellow box to
grow when I mouse over it.
So how do we do that?
Well, we flip over to
our Dart editor.
And this div's ID is
discoverable, so
we'll look it up.
So first we query.
And then we want to see
what events are
available for this div.
So we say, on, and autocomplete
helps us.
And we want a mouse event, so
onMouse, and we'll do Over.
A mouseover produces a
stream of repeated
events when this happens.
So we want to listen
to those events.
And when this happens, we want
to call toggleStyle to--
I've already added the CSS
title to add this little,
bring your attention
to the box.
So we save and refresh.
Now when I mouseover this
div, we've got a nice
little yellow glow.
[APPLAUSE]
EMILY FORTUNA: Also, jQuery is
a super popular framework for
developing your web apps.
And for a couple different
reasons.
It helps with working with CSS
transitions and modifications.
And it also helps eliminate
some cross-browser
differences.
In Dart, we provide these things
in the language itself.
So you don't have to import any
extra libraries, and we
worry about all this for you.
So as an example, let's take
a look at CSS manipulation.
At the very top, we have how you
would add a class in plain
old JavaScript.
And as I mentioned, this
presentation is in Dart.
So we're querying all our
slides, and we're adding this
swing class to the elements.
In jQuery, it's much
more concise.
You just query all your slides,
and you call addClass.
In Dart, we have
the same idea.
We have a collection of the
classes that are applied to
the element.
And we add swing to them.
So as a demo of how this
works, since this is a
presentation written in HTML,
you think, well, great.
I would love to write
all of my other
presentations in HTML.
I really would like to switch
and use the web for all of
these things that I develop.
But in my favorite presentation
software, there's
this great animation effect that
really is important to
drive the point home, and
I can't switch to HTML.
Never fear.
We have ridiculous slide
transitions as well.
So with this little button, I'm
adding this swing class.
And we have absurd slide
transitions.
All right.
Additionally, Dart works--
so JavaScript has, and jQuery
works on, improving your--
eliminating some cross-browser
differences.
So an example, we have WebRTC,
which is the Real Time
Communication protocol for
video chat and such.
And a lot of browsers have
implemented this, but they are
behind various prefixes.
So you have Mozilla
WebKit and so on.
And so if you wanted to use this
in JavaScript, you'd need
to determine which of these was
defined and then call it.
In Dart, we deal with
all of this for you.
So all you'd call
is getUserMedia.
And we determine which browser
you're on and so on.
And the same is for CSS
selectors as well.
So as a little example, we
have our WebRTC demo.
And OK, so this is Chrome,
small potatoes.
Let's switch over to
another browser.
And I will prove that it
works here as well.
Yes.
All right.
Oh, let's stop that.
jQuery has also popularized
the idea of chaining.
How this works is we have a
snippet of jQuery, not how you
would actually write
it in real life.
But what we're doing is we're
applying a bunch of different
styles to this cascades-demo
element.
And so we're calling element.css
repeatedly to
apply all of these different
classes.
jQuery uses--
often, in many of its APIs,
will return the original
calling object.
So it will return this element
so that then, you can chain
your calls.
You could say element.css
textShadow, .css fontFamily,
and so on, so that
you don't have to
repeat yourself as much.
In Dart, we have the
same thing in the
form of method cascades.
And the great thing with method
cascades is they work
on any function in Dart.
So you don't have to rely on the
API designer to write it
that way for you.
You can use it on any
function you want.
So this also works on functions
as well as setters.
So this example, we're setting
a bunch of different styles
using this double dot notation
to set some styles.
And so as a demo, we are setting
the style of our web
page, our HTML presentation.
And what better style to set
than '90s retro webpage?
All right.
We'll go back to the future.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Cool.
So we've seen great things
that we've done so far,
improving that base layer.
How do you actually interact
with HTML.
The next thing we're going to
look at is what happens at a
higher level?
How do you build large
web applications?
Now, I don't know about you,
but sometimes I'm curious
about a very awesome feature
that I see on a webpage.
And I open up the Web
Inspector, and I see
something like this.
Right.
This is actually my Gmail inbox,
and it's obviously not
very readable.
In fact, there, I think that's
actually part of--
each one of those divs can
actually represent one of my
emails as like threads
on the inbox.
But what this highlights is
that we're actually using
something else to
build this app.
It's very unlikely that people
wrote the code this way.
What we have is that people
use frameworks.
And these frameworks actually
generate or try and form the
code and minimize things
in a way that it
will generate that.
Now if you use a different
framework, most likely it's
going to minimize it in a
different way, and they're not
going to be compatible
with each other.
So this is a general
problem on the web.
And many people out there had
been thinking about this and
thinking how to make these
things better.
And it's actually very exciting
times because there
have been now a lot of proposals
and new standards
being proposed to add
a lot of features
to the browser itself.
And the idea is that all the
things that are done by these
frameworks can be supported
directly in the browser.
And that way, they can actually
interoperate more easily.
So you might have actually seen
a lot of this content
earlier in Google I/O, in
different talks, like
different web components
talks and so on.
But I'm going to dive a little
bit more into this in the
perspective of Dart.
Now what are all the
standards about?
There are mainly like two points
I want to highlight.
One is how do you actually
save time and be more
productive writing code so you
don't write glue code, stuff
that is just always the same.
And a typical example of that is
binding your UI in the part
of the view [? view ?]
with your data model.
And it's very common that you
want to actually do that
automatically.
The other part is how do you
actually encapsulate what
you're writing and make it
reusable so you can actually
work with a lot of people,
and you can share
your code with others.
And this is where things like
web components, custom
elements, Shadow DOM, and all
these things come in.
So in Dart, we have this project
called Web UI where we
are keeping pace with what all
these standards are doing and
implement them for you in
Dart so you can start
experimenting, giving us
feedback, so we can actually
give it back [? into ?]
the entire community.
EMILY FORTUNA: And use
them on any browser.
SIGMUND CHEREM: That's right.
So what we're going to do next
is talk in a little bit more
detail about some of
these features.
So the first one I want to talk
about is observability.
In JavaScript, ECMAScript 7,
there's a proposal that has
been accepted to add
the notion of
observing data changes.
So the idea that you can create
an object, and then you
can call something like
Object.observe.
And then after that point, any
time you mutate that object,
you add a property, you change
the value of the property, you
will get notified
in a callback.
So something very similar we're
going to be actually
supporting in Dart.
The way we declare it is
slightly different, just in
the way that the languages are
just slightly different.
In our case, we use an
annotation saying @observable,
and we're going to make it,
that class, in some way
observable.
So once you have this, there's
actually a great
power in your hand.
You can start writing programs
in a more reactive way.
You can listen to the changes
that come from data from the
network and react to that
in your own way.
But it's especially handy when
you want to glue this code
into your UI and
create now data
bindings that are automatic.
EMILY FORTUNA: So as an example
of this, we have a
little counter here.
And this is useful in the
context of our presentation if
we're watching time.
This is counting since we've
refreshed the page.
How do we implement this?
Well, let's take a look
at the Dart code.
We have a Counter class.
And the interesting part
is this down here.
Our timer is every second
incrementing our counter.
OK, so that's fine.
But what does it look like?
How do we notify the web page
to update and redraw?
That's it.
We put in this little double
mustache syntax.
And this tells us that
we need-- we
want to bind the values.
When value is incremented, we
want to update the webpage.
And we, underneath the scenes,
take care of all the
boilerplate of when to update
the view and listening and so
on, so you don't have
to worry about this.
SIGMUND CHEREM: So now the
syntax that you see here might
be actually slightly different
than what you've seen in other
presentations because everything
is actually
changing under our feet,
and we're just
keeping pace with that.
So this is actually likely
going to change in just a
couple days, in fact, to
be slightly different.
So what we just show here
is an example of one
direction of bindings.
You have something changing in
your data model, and you want
to reflect that in the UI.
Another thing that you
might want to do is
go the other way.
You can actually then have an
input box, and then any change
that you make in the input
box be reflected
in your data model.
So here I have a little example
where on the first
line, we have something
that is similar
to what we had before.
I have a model where I'm going
to actually read a value and
put it in my UI.
And on the second line, I have
the input box and the special
attribute bind-value
does the other
direction of the binding.
Now here's the same
code running.
And whenever I type something
here, with typos, you see them
reflected immediately on the
other part of the UI.
So what's going on here is
actually, when you actually
look at the Dart code,
[INAUDIBLE]
is again very simple.
It's just an observable
object, and that's
all I had to write.
Now, bindings are very useful
for these simple examples, but
they actually scale to make
it possible to write more
sophisticated things as well.
Given that we're doing this
presentation in Dart, here's
another interesting thing
that we could do.
Say I want to have an index
of all my slides.
So what I'm showing here is a
little list of all the slide
titles that we have in
this presentation.
And I can even search for them,
and I can say "future."
I can actually click on one of
those slides, and it jumps to
the slide number.
And I can come back.
Now this is all written using
a lot of these bindings and
features that are becoming
available and things like
model-driven views.
So here's what that
code looks like.
What we have in the first two
lines is similar to what you
saw before.
It's an input box where
we're binding the
value of the query.
So any time you type something
in the search box, that's now
bound into the particular
variable.
Then we have this other
variable, matchingTitles, that
is selecting those things
that actually match
that particular query.
And we're using that inside of
a template to do this kind of
iteration process.
We're saying that for every
title that matches, we're
actually creating a list
item in our UI.
And here's essentially where
we're actually putting the
text of the title
in our slide.
And finally, we have this extra
attribute here to hook
up our event listening.
So anytime we click on
it, we're jumping to
a particular slide.
Now, this is actually something
that looks similar
to how normal HTML allowed you
to put, like, event handlers
in JavaScript.
But there's a difference here,
in that we're actually
transforming this and generating
code in a way that
it would actually be efficient
by default.
It's actually doing the code
that you would normally write,
if you want to make it
efficient, by hand.
Like finding the element and
attaching [? event handlers ?]
programmatically.
And it's also made in a way
that is secure by default.
And I want to spend a couple
more seconds talking about
security in general.
So in the Dart team, we care a
lot about how do we actually
make creating web applications
easier.
And one thing that people
stumble a lot is on how do you
protect your application from
things like cross-site
scripting attacks.
When you're using things like
templating, a lot of the
things can actually be prevented
more easily.
Particularly when you see this
binding here, we know that I'm
injecting some content in
the middle of that HTML.
But because I know where I am,
I know for once that, OK, I'm
just been putting text here.
There's no way I can actually
put something
like a script tag.
I know that I'm injecting it
that way when I clearly am
running this code.
And there are many other
things like that,
that you can do.
So even in our .HTML libraries,
we're currently
looking into how we make
something like
[? inner HTML ?]
safer and have either validation
or checks or things
that you can do.
And if you're using templating,
reduce the cost as
much as possible so you
don't see any overhead
[? at runtime. ?]
Cool.
So now that we have these views,
and we know we can
create something really pretty,
the next thing we want
to do is make it reusable.
So this where custom elements
and Shadow DOM and all these
things come along.
So here at the bottom, there's a
little bit of sample syntax.
And you might have seen
this earlier today.
Basically the idea is that I can
define a view and wrap it
with a name.
And I'm going to use this name
as a tag in my HTML.
So here I'm saying the name of
my tag or something like
my-element.
And later on, I can use that tag
in my HTML in the bottom
thing, my-element foo.
EMILY FORTUNA: And the way I
like to think about this is
object-oriented programming
for HTML.
So here, we're simply
declaring our
custom element or class.
And then we're instantiating
it.
And it can varying behavior
depending on each element that
you instantiate.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Exactly.
So one thing that I can
highlight related to that is
that custom elements allow you
to also override or extend the
behavior of other elements
that exist in the DOM.
And in this example we have
here, it is extend div.
And when I see that, I know that
actually this is going to
behave like a block element,
not like a span
element, for example.
And when you instantiate
an element, there's an
alternative syntax that is
based on the fact that it
knows that, OK, there's
some base element
that we know out there.
And I can say, well, this
particular div is an instance
of my-element, which is
a subkind of div.
So I want to switch to the
editor and show you a more
realistic example.
And what we're going to do
is open one slide here.
This slide, in fact, is a
custom element itself.
And what I have here
on the top is a
commented out custom element.
I'm just going to clean this
up and go through the code
little by little so that
we can actually
see what it's doing.
Basically, I'm interested in
adding a slide number to my
presentation.
I just want to know what
slide I'm on right now.
So I'm going to add
a custom element
called my slide number.
It's going to be essentially
a div.
And I'm going to associate with
that element a little bit
of Dart code.
So here in this attribute, where
I say constructor equals
SlideNumber, I'm saying that
this is a class in Dart that I
want to associate
with my element.
Now here at the bottom is a
definition of the class.
It has a bunch of fields.
One of them is, what's the
current slide, which is just
looking that up from
my presentation.
And finally, we have this
template object with this
template tag, where I'm defining
what the actual
element looks like.
And I'm saying, well, it's
actually going to have this
text, and it's going to actually
show the current
slide number.
So let's go to the bottom.
We have here an instance
of this slide number.
I'm going to put
it in my slide.
I'm removing those comments.
We now save, refresh.
And once we're here, you'll see
this is slide number 25.
So once you have one of these
elements, you can actually do
a lot of other things that also
resemble object-oriented
or general programming.
For example, you can actually
pass information to your
custom element using
attributes.
So I can actually put here
something like my-attribute
and say, "Hello Dart!" And what
I have up here is that we
actually already have a field
named myAttribute.
You may have noticed that I have
a little difference in
the syntax.
This is a camelCase
letter here.
This is using dashes.
This is that HTML doesn't
allow you to have case
sensitivity.
So in Dart, we say, well,
let's translate.
Every time you have a dash,
we're going to capitalize the
next word and associate that
with a field in this class
that is associated with
your custom element.
Once we have that, we can
actually just put this
myAttribute in the middle
of my template.
Attribute.
And now when we refresh, we will
see there that it says,
hey,
"Hello Dart!" Cool.
So another thing that you get
with custom elements is that
once you define it once, you can
use it in multiple places.
You don't have to use it only
where you define it.
You can actually also
import it and use it
in other HTML pages.
And the way you do that
is by using this link
rel="import" syntax.
This is another standard out
there from the web community.
And back to our presentation,
let's open another slide here.
This is the slide that has
that particular text.
And I'm just commenting
out the link rel.
And then here at the bottom,
we have the other syntax we
have to create custom
elements.
Our slide number with
our attribute.
And we save, we refresh.
EMILY FORTUNA: So just to
clarify, we're importing from
our original definition
into this slide.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Exactly.
So right here, up here, this
href is essentially the name
of the other slide number.
In fact, if I have a typo, and
I say, oh, I forgot to put
this dot here, and I save.
You actually see some errors
at the bottom.
And actually, I wanted to
highlight this because in
Dart, we have a lot of power
making tools available to you
that actually give you
a lot of feedback.
In particular, the Dart editor
focuses a lot of energy on
analyzing Dart.
But it's also pluggable.
And in our case, with WebUI,
we managed to also add
additional information to
understand the HTML itself.
So here at the bottom,
you see this actual
file doesn't exist.
That's why you see that
red curly line.
But actually, interestingly, you
also this second warning
saying the slide number is
not defined anywhere.
I couldn't find a definition
because, well, it probably
came from that file.
But at least you actually get
some feedback if you actually
had a typo and used the wrong
name of your custom element.
Right.
EMILY FORTUNA: So in this
case, we were passing an
additional, a different
attribute here as well.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Yeah.
EMILY FORTUNA: All right.
So I'm sure you guys were really
blown away by that
slide number example.
And now you want to put it
in all of your web apps.
So the next great step is
fortunately, you can because
we have this package management
system called Pub.
It allows you to share any
Dart code, also custom
elements that you write.
And you can easily
put them into--
work with any project
of your own.
So in this example here,
we are using--
see these little tabs here?
This is actually a custom
element that
neither Siggy nor I wrote.
A third party developer, Kevin
Moore, wrote this.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Who
is right there.
EMILY FORTUNA: He ported a bunch
of bootstrap widgets.
And so the way we added this to
our presentation is all we
had to do is we have this
little pubspec.
We added our widget library.
And then in our HTML, in the
presentation, we added a link
rel, just like we did before.
And then we instantiate
it with his
custom element tab name.
And it's that simple.
And here's another one
that he wrote.
It's a little accordion
widget.
So we went through
a whole bunch of
different things today.
These are some of the resources
that talk about a
lot of these standards that
are being developed.
And if you'd like to read
more, feel free
to check them out.
And everything we've shown you
today is available to try it.
You can download the Dart
SDK, and it will work.
SIGMUND CHEREM: In fact, there
are people already using this.
For example, the Blossom team,
they already actually had been
using and even put up also
some of their widgets in
another package in Pub.
EMILY FORTUNA: And the
Glyph3D app as well.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Oh, the
So there's a lot of things that
are continually changing.
All the standards are actually
still shaping up.
And a lot of things
are basically
moving under our feet.
So as I mentioned earlier,
there's more things coming,
more things changing, and
we're just keeping pace.
Now we're going to
be here around
to answer any questions.
We would love for you guys to
join us in the code lab
tomorrow, where we're going to
actually hands on be using a
lot of these features.
And we're happy to take
questions here.
Then we're afterwards going to
be upstairs in the Dart booth
and in the Office Hours area.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SIGMUND CHEREM: Any questions?
Oh, you're here.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hi.
MARK: Hi.
My name is Mark.
So you're building a very new
language for all the web.
Could it be there's a bigger
picture here for Google, like
you want to use this language in
many of your products like,
for example, Google+?
EMILY FORTUNA: Google is
using Dart internally.
And we hope that these
projects will see the
light of day soon.
MARK: OK.
So it's great to see some
support also from your
company, then, here.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Yeah.
There's definitely commitment
internally to actually
continue using it.
And we're starting to see
adoption as well, and it's
very exciting.
MARK: Thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hi.
PAUL: Hi.
I'm Paul from [INAUDIBLE].
I wanted to ask, is Dart Chrome
extension ready right now?
Because since Chrome team
introduced manifest version
two, there is a content
security policy.
And I wanted to ask,
is this ready for
applications for Chrome?
SIGMUND CHEREM: So to clarify,
you're asking about using Dart
to write your own extension?
MARK: Yeah.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Yes.
Yes, so that's definitely
possible.
There's even a mode in which you
can actually compile your
Dart code into JavaScript and
use it in an extension.
There's a special flag you
need to pass into DartJS
compiler to make it CSP
compliant so it doesn't use
things like [? evolve ?]
and stuff like that.
But it's definitely possible.
PAUL: I am wondering about
developing because when you're
developing, you use
the internal
server in Dart Editor.
And when you develop an
extension, you load this
extension as a file,
as an app.
EMILY FORTUNA: So the only
reason we used a server for
this is for our WebRTC demo
because you can't do that from
file, locally.
PAUL: OK.
So I don't--
EMILY FORTUNA: Everything
else--
PAUL: I don't need to use
the server, right?
SIGMUND CHEREM: Right.
PAUL: OK.
Thanks.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Actually, that's
more or less what I
was going to ask.
But basically, what you showed
us today, typically, you would
have compiled that to a page
that'd be served up, just like
any other static page.
And you'd have to use Ajax and
whatnot, then, to get your
data back and forth, right?
SIGMUND CHEREM: Yes.
I mean, that's definitely--
basically, the deployment step
typically involves something
like that, where you're bundling
all the Dart code and
then shipping essentially just
one JavaScript file or a
couple of JavaScript files that
you want to actually put
in your app, and their
resources.
AUDIENCE: And so the way you
were using the web components
with the data binding, you could
do that using standard
JavaScript objects that you were
pulling via, say, JSON
and then bind them into
the UI that way?
SIGMUND CHEREM: You can use
JSON and things like that.
In the current state, you would
have to still use Dart
in a way to say, OK, given this
JSON, how do I process it
and create Dart objects
out of that?
But then your client-server
interaction
continues to be the same.
You can still have JSON over the
wire and seamlessly work
and support clients that could
talk, for examplee--
or be written in JavaScript that
would actually use JSON
for their rendering.
And you can use Dart
on the other hand.
AUDIENCE: Has that JSON to Dart
object conversions all
been addressed in the
client side then?
SIGMUND CHEREM: Yes.
Yes, there's a Dart call in JSON
library, basically, that
has the JSON parse and
the Stringify APIs.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So I've been playing with Dart
a little bit lately.
And something's been annoying
me about it, and I'm pretty
sure it's due to my ignorance.
I'm hoping you can
help me out.
The way I've usually used web
technologies is I have an
existing project, and I just
add a little bit of jQuery.
Dart, it feels like most of the
learning material says,
start a new project in
the Dart Editor.
And so there's a lot of magic.
And I realize there's
command line tools.
But if I want to use a web
component from Dart in an
existing project, I need to
compile my Dart to JavaScript,
and I need to compile my HTML,
because there are some
transforms.
Is there kind of documentation
for making Dart play nice with
my existing project?
SIGMUND CHEREM: There's some,
but there should be more.
In a brief way, I can say, a
lot things are possible.
But some of the things, there's
still a lot of steps
which we want to take to
actually make things a little
bit more minimalistic.
Like, say you just want this
component, and that's
all that you want.
Those are things that are
still not there yet.
EMILY FORTUNA: And I'd say that
the focus right now is
making one great experience
through the Dart Editor.
And so, yes, we'd love to
expand in future time.
But our current focus
is like one whole
ecosystem that works great.
SIGMUND CHEREM: One great thing
where things are moving
is the new changes that we're
seeing in model-driven views
and in custom elements are
pushing us to also move a lot
more of our logic to be more
dynamic and to work more later
on, so that you don't have
to use so much of the
tools ahead of time.
So I think that's also
going to help.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
SIMON: Hi.
Simon from Quebec City.
Coming from a grid background,
one tool that I heavily rely
on is Maven to manage
my build cycle.
I was wondering if there's such
a tool that you would
recommend for programming Dart,
for managing [INAUDIBLE]
into the build life cycle.
EMILY FORTUNA: Sorry,
what's the tool?
SIMON: Maven.
EMILY FORTUNA: Maven.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Maven.
So I might need some
more context.
So basically, you have a tool
that helps you in the whole
process of building things and
bundling things together and
deployment and such.
SIMON: Yeah, automating testing
and deployment, and
compiling and dependence
management and--
SIGMUND CHEREM: Definitely.
That's something that
we actually started
doing some work on.
And we're hoping that on one
hand, that it should be able
to start using tools
that already exist.
Hopefully, there is nothing
Dart-specific about a lot of
these things.
But we also have moments where
we actually have realized that
having a Dart-specific solution
actually sometimes helps.
And we have a project called
buildtool, for example, that
is starting to look
into this area.
How do you have, for example,
a build server end to your
picture that helps you
coordinate all these things
between different tasks and
steps that you have to do?
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: And op.
SIGMUND CHEREM: And
op, that's true.
Kevin [INAUDIBLE], there's
another project out there that
you can try.
EMILY FORTUNA: In Dart.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
SIGMUND CHEREM: So Pub is
actually, I don't know if--
yeah, Pub handles a lot of the
package management and the
installation process.
So that's another thing
that helps.
And they are adding
the features to do
deployment as well.
So that you can take all the
packages that initially were
distributed and how to minimally
put them together so
that you know what you
have to deploy.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
How does it compare to, or why
is it better than Angular?
SIGMUND CHEREM: It's actually
a little bit of apples and
oranges in that you could
ask the same question.
How do you compare Angular
and the standards?
Right?
And I think that Angular has a
lot of features that are at a
high level.
And they're actually
very rich.
Things like routing, things
like dependence injection.
And I think all this [INAUDIBLE]
can actually be
put on top of what
we have as well.
And I'm hoping that actually,
that's the direction we will
move forward so that the
standards can be a common
ground that you can then pick
and choose different
frameworks and get
something better.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
But I guess the key difference,
really, is you're
programming Dart versus
JavaScript, which hopefully
Dart, the language, makes things
nicer, your overall
development experience.
But we hope to get most of
the same functionality.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Does Dart act as a polyfill
when web components or
templates are not available and
not even in the browser?
I mean, does it--
when compiling to JavaScript,
it emulates that function as
not available?
EMILY FORTUNA: I'm sorry.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Sorry,
I couldn't hear.
AUDIENCE: What components and
templates are part of the W3C
standards, right?
SIGMUND CHEREM: Yes.
So a lot of the standards,
there's the Shadow DOM is
there, custom elements.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
But they're not fully supported
by old browsers.
SIGMUND CHEREM: They're
not today.
AUDIENCE: Does that
do something to
fill this gap when--
SIGMUND CHEREM: So right now,
what we're currently doing is,
yes, filling that gap, creating
an interface that
looks the same and works
in everywhere.
The term that commonly
people talk about,
polyfilling, right.
It's just the same.
So we're doing our version of
that in Dart so that it has
the thing experience.
And ideally, when it's supported
in the browser, then
it's just simply used directly
rather than poly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's all right.
Thanks.
EMILY FORTUNA: We're
out of time.
But we will come talk
to you guys offline.
Or come talk to us.
SIGMUND CHEREM: Yeah,
come to us.
We'll be hanging out here.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thank you.
SIGMUND CHEREM: And we're going
to be upstairs as well
in the booth.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]